Part of the nature of disease is determined by the distinction between organs
and tissues that are either more vulnerable or more robust and organs and
tissues differ considerably in that respect.
This has to do with tissue renewal and repair,
sensitivity to stress,
vulnerability to threats,
which tissues are the weakest physiological links,
and the fact that evolution has designed different tissues and organs to have
different built in safety factors.
All of this occurs within a framework of trade offs and constraints.
Yeah.
It also occurs because tradeoffs leave us exposed to mismatches which reveal the
costs of the tradeoffs.
Okay,
so let's consider this spectrum from from vulnerability to robustness.
Organs and tissues differ in their robustness,
their resilience and their vulnerability.
Robustness means how resistant assistant is to disease and resilience means how
easily a system can return to health.
That mosaic determines the spectrum of diseases,
both in general and in particular environments.
Yeah,
robustness and resilience are often negatively correlated.
Bones,
for example,
resist damage.
So they're robust,
but they're hard to mend.
On the other hand,
epithelium wounds easily,
but it recovers rapidly,
so it's resilient,
but it's not very robust.
Now,
why are all organs and tissues not as robust and resilient as possible?
It's because of tradeoffs producing such structures and processes would cost
more than it would pay?
Yeah.
Let's consider tissue renewal and repair.
Here we have a picture of a bronchial epithelium and some neurons and the rat
spinal cord.
These have different properties,
tissues that have a high renewal rate,
like the bronchiolar epithelium also have a high repair capacity and they're
pretty tolerant to damage.
That's true of most epithelium and the hematopoietic system.
On the other hand,
tissues that have a low renewal rate and a low repair capacity do not tolerate
damage.
That includes neurons and cardiomyocyte.
My
damaged too.
Tissues with a high renewal rate is easily handled.
Comparable damage to things like neurons and cardio.
My seats can be fatal.
Yeah.
What about sensitivity to stress?
Well,
in tissues with high energetic demands rely exclusively on oxidative metabolism,
so that would be neurons and heart.
Muscle
tissues with low energetic demands tolerate hypoxia relatively well because they
can switch from oxidative to glycolytic metabolism,
so that would be a dipocytes fibroblasts.
Hematopoietic cells.
Yeah,
no,
that's why is Kenya the lack of oxygen and nutrients rapidly in seriously
damages brains,
hearts and kidneys,
often irreversibly,
sometimes fatally.
So these are the tissues that really need oxygen and are prioritized by our
circulatory system to keep them going.
When oxygen levels drop,
then there is vulnerability to threats.
Protective structures have evolved to shield vulnerable,
Oregon's from frequently and clown or threats.
So the skull protects the brain.
The Rib cage protects the heart and lungs.
Some tissues and organs are immune privileged.
Here we have pictures of a couple of them.
They don't permit immune responses that have damaging side effects.
Inflammation for example.
So brain eyes and gonads are all immune privileged and they do not inflame
easily when infected,
however,
a prices paid and the price is by avoiding the cost of inflammation,
they make themselves vulnerable to pathogens that can get into them.
Okay,
so what are the weakest physiological links?
The consequences of losing function very widely.
Lung tissues and organs.
If you have mild damage,
deliver Skinner intestinal epithelium that can be tolerated,
repaired.
It's often not lethal uncomfortable,
but not lethal equivalent damage to the pulmonary.
The cardiovascular or to the central nervous system causes severe disease and
even death.
So these are the weakest links in the body.
They're malfunction kills in their failure is a frequent cause of death in the
agent.
It is.
Therefore,
the weakest links were special features of evolve to protect against
catastrophic failure
built in safety factors are part of those protections.
The safety factor is the ratio of functional capacity to expected maximal load.
So for example with bodyweight is w and the skeleton can bear a weight of four w
than the safety factor of the skeleton is for.
Yeah,
increasing the safety factor has cost.
In this case,
further strengthening the skeleton would decrease mobility.
That's a tradeoff.
The greater the safety factor,
the greater the resistance to damage,
but also the larger the costs of resistance.
Here are a few safety factors for biological materials.
Human Pancreas,
about 10 the wing bones of a flying goose,
about six human kidneys both for the leg bones of running ostrich,
2.5 the human small intestine about two in the backbone of a weight lifter
between one and two.
Yeah.
Our vulnerability is explained by trade offs and constraints.
Many structures are vulnerable because of compromises that are imposed by
tradeoffs.
So for example,
here's a synovial joint.
The wrist,
the elbow,
the finger,
the shoulder and the knee are all synovial joints and they have superior
mobility.
Yeah,
but they are vulnerable to arthritis.
Yeah.
Alveolar sacs in our lungs have excellent gas exchange,
but they are vulnerable to pneumonia when they're filled with inflammatory
exited.
So you can see that there are vulnerabilities and costs that are built into
things which otherwise are highly adaptive.
Other structures are vulnerable because of historical constraints.
One of the classic ones is the blind spot in the Vertebra.
I,
here's a vertebrate,
I contracted with an octopus I the red is the retina,
the photo sensitive cells,
the octopus has the retina lining the cup of the eye with the nerve fibers
behind it.
The vertebrate I has the nerve fibers wining the cup of the eye with the retina
behind it and the nerve fibers have to go through the retina at some point to
get to the brain and that is the blind spot.
This difference in the structure of the eyes has persisted for about 500 million
years and probably has to do with the developmental constraint on the
relationship of inducing tissues.
Yeah,
tradeoffs.
We've mentioned many times they're very important after sufficient evolution in
a stable environment,
the cost benefit balance of a tradeoff has usually been optimized.
However,
sufficient evolution in a stable environment is actually a very special case.
Okay.
Effects of disturbance can be serious when the trade off involves large benefits
that are balanced by large costs.
Yeah.
Pathologies can then result for two reasons.
The mechanism controlling the balance of the trade off or perturbed or the
environment changes.
For example,
the immune defense against infection is a large benefit.
It brings with it however high costs of immunopathology and the risks of sepsis
and of electric shock and auto immune disease.
Yeah.
The clotting system is a very large benefit which helps us to heal rapidly if we
sustain damage to our circulatory system,
but it carries the risk of embolism and stroke
mismatch.
Also an important concept.
Frequently mentioned.
If the environment changes,
the cost may exceed the benefits until evolution catches,
and that can take quite awhile.
Modern hygienic environments are abnormal.
They elicit pathological immune responses that include asthma,
allergies,
excema,
and auto immune diseases.
Here's an example of Excema on the four owners of a patient,
changes in Diet and an inflammation increased the risk of clotting disorders.
So to summarize,
the morphology and physiology of the patient is a mosaic of tissues,
organs,
processes,
and structures that vary in their vulnerability to damage their capacity for
repair,
their sensitivity to stress,
and they're built in safety factors.
The key idea here is tradeoffs.
Each of these features has benefits and costs.
When perturbations shift the cost benefit balance,
they elicit pathologies.
That is situations in which the costs are greater than the benefits.